[Música]
hola bienvenidos a este especial de
noticias en france 24 soy natalia
cabrera 2020 un año sin precedentes en
la historia reciente y que en américa
latina' dejó como víctimas colaterales a
los derechos de las mujeres revisemos
tres aristas de como las restricciones
para contener el kobe 19 agudizaron
algunos problemas para nosotras
si bien la violencia contra las mujeres
en la región es un fenómeno de larga
data
las tasas de feminicidios y violencia
sexual se incrementaron exponencialmente
durante los confinamientos
y es que la mayoría de los gobiernos
latinoamericanos centraron sus esfuerzos
en paliar la emergencia sanitaria
dejando de lado la salud sexual y
reproductiva de las mujeres lo que
dificultó el acceso a métodos
anticonceptivos los abortos inseguros
aumentaron en una región donde la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
sigue siendo un tabú
y desde méxico hasta chile a principios
de 2020 los movimientos feministas en
américa latina' estaban en auge con la
llegada de los primeros confinamientos
en marzo al margen de la celebración del
'día internacional de la mujer' esta
lucha contra la violencia machista y
otros reclamos tuvo que buscar otros
espacios nos la cuenta marina sardiña
periodista de la redacción de france 24
quien estuvo a cargo de la producción de
este especial
y comenzamos la violencia contra las
mujeres en américa latina' es una
pandemia silenciosa que deja cifras
alarmantes el confinamiento agravó las
múltiples formas de violencia a las que
se enfrentan las latinoamericanas a
diario muchas de ellas quedaron
encerradas con sus agresores lo que
intensificó la violencia doméstica los
feminicidios aumentaron con las
restricciones al menos 1.500 mujeres
fueron asesinadas en 19 países entre
marzo y junio
las cifras siguen siendo inconclusas
debido a las diferentes tipificaciones
de feminicidios que hace cada país pero
en una investigación del portal
independiente de distintas latitudes que
se basó en fuentes gubernamentales
coloreo la situación de la región miren
los países en morado oscuro son los que
registraron más feminicidios mientras
que los que están en lila tienen una
tasa un poco menor en colombia se
registraron al menos 154 feminicidios
entre marzo y junio en brasil que es el
país que registró el mayor aumento
durante los meses de cuarentena o al
menos 429 feminicidios méxico sumó al
menos 262 muertes violentas de mujeres
en el primer mes de cuarentena en el
salvador se registraron más feminicidios
que muertes por kobe 19 durante la
cuarentena obligatoria nos acompaña
desde ciudad de méxico isabel
erreguerena ella es coordinadora de
políticas públicas de la organización x
justicia para las mujer
isabel gracias por estar con nosotros en
france 24 y comienzo por preguntarle a
qué se debe el aumento de los
feminicidios en países latinoamericanos
durante el confinamiento y la pandemia y
cuáles son los focos rojos en la región
claro sin duda la pandemia ha
representado muchos riesgos en materia
de violencia contra la mujer esto
básicamente porque un lugar de riesgo
históricamente en latinoamérica para las
mujeres es la casa entonces el
confinamiento nos pone en la casa
en este sentido y muchas veces nos
estamos pues con nuestros agresores en
casa y somos mucho más vulnerables a
vivir violencia que en su expresión
máxima termino en feminicidios esto por
una parte tiene que ver con el lugar
también ha dificultado en gran medida si
bien muchos países como son el caso de
argentina-perú han incrementado las
llamadas al 911 pues en el caso de
méxico por ejemplo hemos tenido un
aumento en las llamadas improcedentes de
auxilio por violencia contra las mujeres
porque porque muchas de las mujeres
marcan a pedir ayuda al número y entra
al agresor al cuarto entonces no pueden
pedir ayuda dificulta también la salida
hacia refugios donde puedes pedir ayuda
cuando tu vida está en riesgo y por otra
parte también tenemos cómo se ha
incrementado el trabajo de cuidados para
las mujeres y también el tema de después
la crisis económica ha causado que
muchas de las mujeres salgamos de el
esquema laboral ahora tener que tener ya
sea por despidos o por cuidar a nuestros
nuestros dependientes económicos y esto
nos vuelve mucho más dependientes
económicamente
a veces de nuestros agresores
asimismo bien vemos que los asesinatos
continúan y han incrementado en la casa
y no se establecen políticas como tal de
prevención
como tal no necesariamente las
instituciones se están adaptando
adecuadamente al contexto para dar
respuesta a esta violencia sí
precisamente cuéntanos entonces cuáles
rutas y planes de contingencia con el
foco de enfoque de género deberían tener
los gobiernos latinoamericanos para
disminuir este tipo de violencias
sin duda tenemos que favorecer pues las
ayudas un poco digamos o las
instituciones las políticas públicas que
se pueden llevar a cabo a distancia un
ejemplo de esto es como en diferentes
países como argentina chile perú se ha
fortalecido las llamadas de emergencia
esto no necesariamente ha pasado en
méxico por otro lado las políticas
públicas para reaccionar a esta
violencia tienen también que adaptarse y
aquí también ha habido un tema muy
interesante que es si el uso de la
tecnología pero qué pasa para las
mujeres que es bien importante decir que
no todas las mujeres vivimos la misma
violencia no es lo mismo los obstáculos
que vive una mujer en un en un en la
ciudad de una mujer en lo rural entonces
hay que tener cuidado de apostarle
únicamente a lo tecnológico para darnos
cuenta también a quienes estamos dejando
fuera entonces si bien ha habido un en
muchos de los países que no es el caso
de méxico hay un avance
en mecanismos para denunciar
telefónicamente las instituciones no
están teniendo tampoco
pues la infraestructura para reaccionar
a estas pues está aumento en la
violencia
isabel erreguerena de la organización x
justicia para las mujeres muchas gracias
por acompañarnos en france 24
y el covent 19 también impactó
profundamente los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos de las mujeres en américa
latina y el caribe con énfasis en el
aborto una práctica que solo es
completamente legal en tres países de la
región veamos el informe de marinas
ardilla
en américa latina' más del 97% de las
mujeres en edad fértil viven en países
donde la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo es un delito y se estiman entre
5.000 y 10.000 muertes anuales por
abortos clandestinos una situación que
ha empeorado debido al confinamiento que
estimuló esta práctica
organizaciones como las parteras en
colombia ayudan a mujeres sin recursos a
interrumpir el embarazo de forma segura
en colombia el rostro de las mujeres
judicial izadas y criminalizadas por
aborto es el rostro de mujeres jóvenes
campesinas indígenas y rurales negras
entonces es importante que el aborto
como derecho llegue a sus territorios y
a sus lugares al menos 18 millones de
latinoamericana se quedaron sin acceso a
métodos anticonceptivos debido al
coronavirus según uno mujeres el
aislamiento y las restricciones de
movilidad dificultaron la planeación
familiar tanto en el sector público
centrado en contener la pandemia como en
el privado debido a la caída de ingresos
en los hogares incrementando el número
de embarazos no planeados en hasta 17
millones y por ende los abortos
inseguros con más de 1.000 muertes
maternas en países de bajos o medios
ingresos
además américa latina y caribe es la
única región del mundo en el que la tasa
de gestación de menores de 15 años
aumentó desde 2019 que una niña
menor de 18 años se case sea madre
implica la mayoría de los casos que su
futuro potencial de tener un trabajo o
de estudiar se queda y el derecho de las
mujeres latinoamericanas a decidir sobre
sus cuerpos sigue siendo la deuda
pendiente y una necesidad urgente para
evitar miles de muertes cada año
ahora revisemos el impacto económico de
la pandemia en las mujeres que
representan el 54 por ciento del mercado
laboral informal en américa latina'
las condiciones de vida de las 58
millones de mujeres rurales que habitan
la región ha empeorado con al menos 6
millones en riesgo de pobreza extrema
las mujeres han estado al frente del
cuidado en los hospitales con más del
70% de la carga laboral lo que conlleva
a una mayor exposición al virus pese a
percibir al menos un 28% menos de dinero
que los hombres una situación que
profundiza la brecha salarial
adicionalmente ellas asumen el grueso
del trabajo de cuidado no remunerado de
niños y ancianos una sobrecarga que
dificulta su empoderamiento le
preguntamos a mariana ardila abogada de
la organización women's link como
acentúa la pandemia de las desigualdades
económicas de las mujeres
muchos de los países en la mayoría de
los países en las que trabajamos en
américa latina de gwinnett link hemos
visto que se ha aumentado las horas que
se dedican al cuidado doméstico y al
trabajo doméstico no remunerado por
ejemplo en bogotá se dice que las
mujeres dedican 31 horas semanales al
trabajo doméstico no remunerado y los
hombres 14 horas
entonces
y algunas políticas de los estados
no han tenido en cuenta esta diferencia
que no sea eliminada por la pandemia
sino que más bien se ha acentuado y esto
digamos va a tener un impacto en
en digamos en los avances que durante
varios años se habían hecho en materia
de equidad laboral iba a dejar hacer
retroceder muchos de esos avances y el
cbit 19 llegó a américa latina' el 26 de
febrero a brasil por esos días al margen
de la celebración del día internacional
de la mujer el 8 de marzo las
latinoamericanas salieron a las calles
desde méxico hasta argentina por sus
derechos sin saber que poco después la
región quedaría aislada bajo estrictos
confinamientos nos acompañó en estudio
marina sardiña ella es periodista de
france 24 encargada de la producción de
este especial marina que pasó en 2020
con los movimientos feministas y que se
viene en 2021 si natalia américa latina'
se encontraba en plena ola feminista
pero el movimiento tuvo que trasladar la
lucha por la igualdad y los derechos de
las mujeres de las plazas a las redes
sociales las activistas continuaron
visibilizando y rechazando las
violencias a las que se enfrentan las
mujeres en un momento en el que las
restricciones provocaron un aumento en
las cifras de violencia de género
ahora con el alivio de las medidas de
seguridad las latinoamericanas ambos
a poner el grito en la esfera pública
como demostraron las masivas marchas del
pasado 25 de noviembre día internacional
de la eliminación de la violencia contra
la mujer lejos de entrar en cuarentena
los movimientos feministas y las
organizaciones que lideran las luchas
por las mujeres han encontrado nuevos
espacios para sus reivindicaciones
haciendo visibles otras problemáticas
que incrementaron durante la pandemia
como la violencia de las mujeres trans o
las desigualdades de las mujeres rurales
bueno marina vamos a ver qué nos trae el
2021 para los derechos de las mujeres
ella es marina sardina periodista de la
redacción de france 24 gracias a ustedes
por acompañarnos en este especial nos
dejamos con esta canción que se llama
canción sin miedo un himno por los
derechos de las mujeres que nació en
méxico y que ya fue adaptado a las
necesidades de las colombianas sigan
viendo france24
que tiemble el estado los cielos las
calles
[Música]
ayala
crecieron
a mí no